Microservices architecture is a pattern for organizing computer systems into services that can scale with demand
Back in the 1990's an internet company would run a big monolithic program on a server that the company maintained
on-premise
To serve an increase in traffic a popular company would simply add more instances of the monolith
Monolithic architectures do have some positive features
A monolith centralizes the codebase so it is in one place
Engineers can step through any part of the code when they are debugging
Also user requests that are completely served by a monolith do not have to make many calls across a network
Which reduces the chance of Network failures
Most software companies have their code in a monolith today
When those monoliths get big problems can start to occur
Centralized code leads to tight couplings that are hard to break up
If a program is too big it will be impossible to run on a typical machine
Internet giants in the early 2000s began breaking up their applications into services
Instead of scaling the monolithic application
a service-oriented architecture could scale the parts of an application that were under load
Operating system virtualization made service-oriented architecture more economical
One server could host multiple virtualized operating system instances and each of those instances could run a service
But this also meant that engineers had to manage more and more layers of infrastructure the virtual machine hosts
the hypervisor layer and
the hardware itself
Failures became more complex
Debugging got harder
In 2006 Amazon Web Services launched the Elastic Compute cloud
Ec2 allows programmers to rent virtual machines in Amazon's data centers. With Amazon taking care of failures at the hardware level
and the hypervisor level
Programmers could focus on the virtual machine hosts themselves where their application code was running
But using an entire virtual machine to run a small piece of application code is wasteful
Containers allow a virtual machine to be sliced up into isolated filesystem regions
A container can be as large as the entire VM or as small as your smallest service. Hence the term micro services
Micro services run in containers which run on a virtual machine which runs on a hypervisor which runs on a server
Which sits in Iraq which sits in a data center, which is part of a network of data centers called the cloud
Containerized architecture it led to a new problem
Companies that ran thousands of micro services in containers on the cloud did not have a simple way of managing them
Kubernetes is an open source project from Google that gives engineers a centralized system for managing containers
Kubernetes also makes those services portable
Creating a competitive tension between Amazon Web Services and Google cloud platform
both of which can host kubernetes clusters
The days of micro services are just getting started
Software development has never been easier and the two biggest companies in the cloud are competing for users
It's going to keep getting easier and cheaper